American world war II movies definitely have their own John rhe.
They typically deal with the American sense of duty sacrifice and focus on a
hero,
participating in a battle against good and evil Vietnam war movies have their
own genre to centering on conspiracy distrust and moral ambiguity.
But is there a genre for the Iraq war? What do Iraq war films have in common?
It's certainly possible that not enough time has passed for a strong narrative
about the American occupation of Iraq,
but it's been 17 years since we invaded in 2003 and almost 30 years since the
first Gulf war in that same time period. After the start of the Vietnam war,
we had classics like apocalypse now, and the deer Hunter,
these films had already defined the Vietnam war genre,
the anti-war movement sweats,
the U S and defined the themes in films like platoon,
where the American soldiers are. The antagonists,
the chaos and senseless violence in the film shows us how the country felt about
the war. At that time,
the genre elements of world war II and Vietnam war movies reflect American
feelings about those conflicts.
But what are the genre elements of Iraq war films?
Let's see if we can find any common threads.
What's the best way to go about this army. One of these things,
the way you don't die, sir.
One of the most prominent Iraq war films is Kathryn.
Bigelow's 2008 best picture winner. The hurt locker. It's about a reckless,
but prolific explosive ordinance disposal technician,
and his team as they count down their days until deployment is over.
Sergeant James is the best of the best.
He's technologically gifted unfazed by high stress situations and is in and out
with little to no mess. In short he's a specialist,
Iraq war films typically focus on special forces.
And that's because unlike in world war II and Vietnam,
there was no draft that draft made war something everyone had to possibly
participate in whether they wanted to or not.
That's my world war II and Vietnam films tend to focus on the grunts,
the enlisted infantry men who are just cogs in a much larger machine.
They are the every man, Tom Hanks is a school teacher in saving private Ryan.
And the main characters in the deer. Hunter are steel mill workers.
These films tell the stories of average Joes who get caught up in the chaos and
can't wait to go home.
I was going to him now and finding him so he can go home.
If that earns me the right to get back to my wife. Well, then,
then that's my mission.
Indirect contrast. Iraq war films are about people who want to be there.
And sometimes they actually thrive in the chaos without a draft.
The Iraq war was more removed from everyday American life.
Add in the fact that a large part of the military in the middle East was made up
of mercenary contractors and the American army turned into a job for just a
select few who chose to be there. Iraq war,
movie center on a warrior class of specialized units, such as in the films,
American sniper, zero dark 30, and the hurdle.
Got tools got to right let's rock and roll. Man.
Sergeant James in the hurt locker perfectly embodies the warrior class mentality
of American soldiers in the Iraq war.
He's a specialized elite soldier equipped to deal with the exact nature of the
war and his first scene in combat.
He expertly diffuses a roadside bond right off the bat.
We see he has the technical expertise that an enlisted soldier would not have.
And his technical expertise applies to more than just a fusing the bomb itself
before he diffuses the bomb.
He also diffuses a tense situation with an Iraqi civilian.
The film sets up Sergeant James as a warrior soldier that can do it all.
He not only diffuses bombs, he also diffuses conflict.
So a key Shandra element of many Iraq war films is the painting of American
soldiers as vocational well-trained warriors that can deal with both combat and
civilian occupation.
American sniper focuses on a highly specialized sniper who can spot a bad guy
amongst the civilians and other films like lone survivor and zero dark 30
exclusively show elite special forces who avoid civilian casualties.
Active Valor took this fixation on specialized forces to the extreme and
recruited real life seals to portray themselves clearly playing into the
admiration of elite talent.
The emphasis on small elite groups and their interactions with civilians makes
these films feel intimate and personal.
Most of these films dive into the psychology of being a soldier.
Trauma is a common topic in many Iraq war films.
Many of the films show the soldiers at home and the trauma that they bring with
them.
These films are very sympathetic to the ordeals that a soldier goes through,
which contrasts the infamously poor treatment of Vietnam soldiers by the
American public. When they returned home,
there are quite a few Iraq war films that focus heavily on the trauma of combat
like yellow birds. Thank you for your service and American sniper,
which devotes its last act to addressing Chris Kyle's post traumatic stress
disorder. Spending more time on the psychological effects of war shows.
America's new understanding of mental illness and contrast with earlier war
films that either overlooked trauma resolved it easily or went to the extreme
and showed soldiers as just psychotic,
but highlighting the trauma of American soldiers and limiting the scope of the
film to a specialized few has a secondary effect.
It ends up avoiding broader questions about whether the Iraq war was justified
in the first place like many Iraq war films,
the hurt locker treats America's presence in the war as fact,
and does not question the war in any meaningful way at another film that also
overlooks the morality of the Iraq war is the most successful Iraq war, movie,
American sniper.
Protecting my guys. They were trying to kill our soldiers and, uh,
I'm willing to meet my creator and ask for every shot that I took.
Chris Kyle is the prime example of a dutiful soldier in the film.
He's motivated exclusively by a desire to protect the lives of his teammates.
He's willing to put himself in extremely dangerous situations.
If it means he can save lives, I'm going to go clear houses with Marines.
And though these experiences caused him trauma.
The film ultimately tells us it's worth it because he saved American lives.
Your dad, he's a hero on the surface.
This stance appears a political because Kyle is just protecting soldiers in
dangerous situations,
but did those soldiers have to be there in the first place earlier in the film,
Chris Kyle's dad lectures him on the importance of using violence to protect
others. And while he lectures,
the film cuts to Chris as a child using violence to protect his brother.
When there are those who are blessed with the gift of aggression and the
overpowering need to.
This scene clearly serves as an analogy for Chris's role as a sniper in the Iraq
war. He's just using violence to protect people in danger.
But if you look at this fight as a metaphor for the Iraq war,
the moral justification breaks down, what's beating up this other kid,
really the only option to protect his brother.
And did he really have to continue punching the other kid even after his brother
already escaped?
Even though the film appears to not take a stance one way or the other on the
validity of the war,
the narrow focus on the individual totally simplifies the moral greatness of the
actual Iraq invasion. Nowhere along the way,
does it consider that the best way to support the troops is to keep them out of
harm's way in the first place. And it never questions.
Whether troops are actually improving the situation in Iraq,
the film tries to evoke the same feeling Americans had during world war two.
There was good and evil, and we had to fight on the side of good,
no matter the color.
I just want to believe in what we're doing here. Oh, there's evil here.
We've seen it in reality.
Iraq war has much more in common with the moral grayness of Vietnam because both
conflicts have since been seriously questions all across the political spectrum.
So really American sniper tries to give a world war two type moral absolutism to
a Vietnam award type conflict and other popular Iraq war films.
Also try redressing the Iraq war with a morally righteous story.
Zero dark 30 is honest about some controversial aspects of the war,
but it's still avoids questioning the war itself.
The film justifies the shocking torture scenes by having the torture result in
crucial information about Ben lien's. Whereabouts in reality,
America discovered bid LUNs location from surveillance,
not torture and torture has been routinely questioned as an effective
interrogation tactic, just like American sniper.
This film creates a scenario where the justification for violence appears
obvious,
but only because the film framed that scenario in a way that overlooks the
broader context of the war.
Contrast these films with film flight platoon and the deer Hunter were the
horrors of war crimes are addressed head on and clearly portrayed as a mistake
or even world war II films like saving private Ryan.
Where interesting questions do get raised about the justification of their
mission because world war II and Vietnam war films make moral judgments about
their respective conflicts.
That honesty allows them to address more interesting questions about war in
general, overall mainstream Iraq, war films,
focus on specialized experts and their individual experiences in combat.
And that focus means that these films rarely address moral issues about the Iraq
war as a whole, not to mention they completely overlook the Iraqi perspective.
Maybe this is why the genre doesn't have its apocalypse. Now,
if a war film wants to be truly great,
it needs to confront the messy reality of the war that it's about.
Although most mainstream Iraq war films avoid the messy realities.
There are some films that do address American involvement in the middle East in
challenging ways.
Are you even doing here? I got lost on the way up.
It's a 2005 film about infantry men in the Gulf war, though.
It is about a different war. Its time of release setting and subject matter.
Make it feel comparable to an Iraq war film and unlike most Iraq war films
Jarhead does have something insightful say about American involvement in the
middle East in the film Swafford character.
Satirizes the American fantasy of a morally justified war effort.
It feels almost as if Swafford watched American sniper and got the impression
that he could be a hero too. But from the beginning,
the film rejects the idea that he's a morally righteous character doing the
right thing. He was manipulated into joining the military. He's sickly,
obsessed with killing the bank. And in the end,
he was completely worthless to the war effort.
I never shot her right after a grueling experience in bootcamp and months of
waiting in the hot desert, all the soldiers want is to get into battle.
But when it finally comes the enemy retreats almost instantly American air
power, easily overpowered the Iraqi army.
Like a slope. They already retreat. All right,
we can shoot a thousand yards to go that far in Vietnam.
That would take a week more one a year here. It's going to take about 10.
They then spend the rest of the film, walking through the carnage,
wrought by a war that moves too fast for them.
And when Swafford finally gets his chance to fire his weapon.
What the frequency are you all. We got here.
Like other Iraq war films. It focuses on the experience of the American soldier,
but that experience is not one of duty and honor.
It's one of psychological torture, the scars they bring home,
aren't shown as sacrifices for our freedom. Instead, the film leaves you asking,
what was it all for?
In one particularly poignant scene Swafford and his battalion cheer on the
flight of the Valkyries scene from apocalypse now as if it's a football game,
but that scene is itself a satire of military heroism. So when they cheer it on,
they're obviously missing the point.
The film even gets cut off before the explosion start.
So they never get their climactic ending.
This scene shows the soldiers failure to even imagine a morally justified
conflict. They completely misread the messaging and apocalypse.
Now a film that actually reflects the chaos and pointlessness of the Vietnam
war. This scene feels like a commentary on war films. In general,
it's saying that people who watch war films struggled to see the immorality of
war when focusing just on the spectacle of American soldiers in combat and films
like American sniper and zero dark 30 further remove films from reality by
creating moral dilemmas that avoid asking the actual tough questions,
but Jarhead does capture the true moral ambiguity of the Wars in Iraq.
In reality,
the Gulf war and Iraq war were far more complex and Jarhead addresses the
pointlessness of American involvement in the middle East.
Instead of relying on a simple support, our trips narrative,
that doesn't really have anything insightful to say about war,
whether you support it, the war or war against it.
The reality is that many Americans felt like Swafford watching a war that didn't
make sense completely unable to either help or stand against it. We are still
in the Tesser jar,
had had a mixed reviews when it came out in 2005,
those skepticism of the war was high.
Americans may have been disappointed with a meandering story without the violent
catharsis they thought they would get when they bought their tickets to a war
film. But looking back, it might've been ahead of its time to this day.
We are still involved in military operations in the middle with no end in sight.
The violence that happens abroad is abstract and removed from the American
people,
films like the hurt locker and American sniper represent an escapist desire to
create clear lines between good and evil in the middle East.
But the reality is far more complex.
There's still plenty of time for more films like Jarhead to come out that bring
a more nuanced take on ideas of heroism and violence. And I think they will.
But while that happens, we're all still in the dark.
[Inaudible].
You liked the topic of this video. We also recorded a podcast episode,
talking more in depth about war movies,
click on the link in the description to listen to it yourself and give us
feedback on what you think.
And it's always a big thanks to our Patrion supporters who watched this video a
week in advance and got early access to the podcast.
For watching.